[Música]
ya de regreso en la casa blanca en un
acto cuidadosamente orquestado el
presidente de donald trump se quitó la
mascarilla protectora mientras posaba
para los fotógrafos tras tres noches
hospitalizado el mandatario se está
recuperando de kobe 19 paralelo a una
ola de infecciones en la casa
presidencial incluyendo a su portavoz
kelly mckinney
cifra récord de contagios en mexico
fueron más de 28 mil nuevos casos de
coronavirus y el país superó ya las 80
mil muertes la nación azteca es la
primera en tasa de letalidad por kobe 19
y además es actualmente la cuarta causa
de muerte a nivel nacional
y el opositor ruso alexéi navalni
publicó su primer vídeo tras recuperarse
de un envenenamiento con el agente
nervioso no [__] que aseguró que los
servicios de inteligencia de rusia lo
intoxicaron como una amenaza antes de
las elecciones parlamentarias del
próximo año
regresamos con ustedes para actualizar
la información más importante de américa
latina y del mundo en eeuu el presidente
de donald trump llegó ya a la casa
blanca tras ser dado de alta del
hospital walter reed donde se trataba
por kobe 19 lo primero que hizo fue
quitarse la mascarilla el mandatario
instó a los ciudadanos a salir y les
dijo que no tengan miedo del virus
informan andrés meza muñoz y marinas
ardilla
como una señal de victoria o de
escepticismo frente al kobe 19 el
presidente de donald trump se quitó la
mascarilla tras llegar a la casa blanca
pese a que todavía no está fuera de
peligro según dijeron sus médicos
aprendí mucho acerca del virus y una
cosa es segura no dejen que los domine
no le tengan miedo van a vencer
y ahora estoy mejor y quizás soy inmune
el mandatario publicó este mensaje en su
cuenta de twitter y aquí se ve como
interactúo con un grupo de personas
durante varios minutos para producir el
vídeo mientras permanecía sin mascarilla
la actitud de trump calificada de
irresponsable se ha dejado ver
repetidamente en esta oportunidad que
instó a sus ciudadanos a salir a las
calles y el domingo dejó brevemente el
hospital walter reed para saludar a sus
seguidores y que no se puede engañar
sobre ciertas cosas y no digo que lo
hayan hecho si de hecho el presidente
había realmente contraído el virus y lo
sabía antes de salir en público ya sabes
los encuentros y no llevaba una
mascarilla eso es otra cosa
cualquiera que contraiga el virus
diciendo que las mascarillas no importan
el distanciamiento no importa creo que
es responsable de lo que les pasa que es
con este comportamiento trump llega a
una casa blanca donde el virus sigue
propagándose principalmente entre
quienes asistieron a la ceremonia de
nominación de la jueza e miconi barre a
la corte suprema los casos más recientes
fueron la secretaria de prensa del
presidente y dos de sus asistentes
eeuu ya superó las 210 mil muertes por
kobe 19 y el número de contagios se
acerca a los 7 millones y medio
méxico registró este lunes una cifra
récord de nuevos contagios por cubrir 19
con más de 28 mil nuevos casos y cerca
de 2 mil 800 muertes superando la
barrera de 80 mil las cifras reales
pueden ser mucho mayores debido a que
hay un déficit de pruebas además la
nación cambio su sistema de conteo y
ahora incluye a personas con síntomas
asociados pero sin prueba maría clara
calle nos cuenta la situación
méxico superó las 80 mil muertes más que
un número esta realidad marca la
tendencia de que el país norteamericano
es el que tiene la mayor tasa de
letalidad del mundo es decir la mayor
cantidad de muertes por cada 100
contagios confirmados con 10,4 por
ciento las estadísticas de la
universidad johns hopkins muestran que
comparativamente los fallecimientos han
afectado a méxico por encima de países
como reino unido- ecuador irán y francia
esta realidad parecía distante del 18 de
marzo cuando murió por coronavirus la
primera persona en el país un hombre de
74 años que padecía diabetes pocos días
después el presidente de andrés manuel
lópez obrador invitó a los mexicanos a
salir a las calles desde un restaurante
en oaxaca
somos muy resistentes
todas las calamidades siempre hemos
salido adelante y en esta ocasión vamos
a salir adelante
el presidente mexicano también recomendó
abrazarse en contravía de los
lineamientos de la organización mundial
de la salud pero a medida que los
contagios crecieron hasta convertir a
méxico en uno de los países latinos con
más diagnósticos positivos
lópez obrador flexibilizó su discurso
aunque nunca impuso un aislamiento
generalizado para todo el país si
comenzó a insistir en los cuidados
básicos en agosto méxico anunció junto
con argentina que produciría para toda
américa latina la vacuna que desarrolla
el laboratorio británico de astra set
pero el laboratorio pasó momentáneamente
sus ensayos clínicos por efectos
adversos en los pacientes que
posteriormente reanudó ahora méxico al
igual que el resto del mundo sigue a la
espera de la inyección mientras que sus
cifras demuestran que la pandemia no da
desde ciudad de méxico nos acompaña para
el análisis javier tello médico cirujano
y experto en políticas de salud javier
gracias por estar con nosotros en france
24 en qué etapa de la pandemia estamos
en mexico ya se llegó a la famosa meseta
después de la cual las cifras tendrían
que bajar
hola qué tal no la realidad es que
nosotros hemos estado en valla nos hemos
mantenido continuamente crecientes en
torno a contagios y en torno a muertes
lo que había ocurrido es que no se
habían estado contabilizando bien ambas
cosas número uno en méxico no estamos
haciendo ni por error el número de
pruebas que deberíamos estar haciendo
sino porque por el contrario las pruebas
han venido disminuyendo si uno disminuye
las pruebas va a captar menos pacientes
además las pruebas no se están haciendo
a todas las personas que debieran
estarse haciendo en este sentido
pareciera como que habíamos estado en un
periodo de meseta lo mismo ocurrió con
las muertes la gente no está muriendo
visiblemente en muchos hospitales en
donde se está certificando porque no hay
pruebas y muchos pasan vamos a llamarle
por debajo del radar es bien sabido que
en méxico mucha gente está muriendo en
su casa y que mucha gente está muriendo
sin que quede certificada lo que ocurrió
ahora
es que con un ajuste en la metodología
que ocurrió el mes pasado comenzaron a
contabilizar casos que no se habían
considerado como com y 19 y son los que
de repente metieron de la hoja de excel
hacia toda la estadística de golpe más
de 20 mil contagios y más de 2 mil 700
muertes esto de todos modos es
inaceptable porque nos dice que el
sistema había estado mal para llevar una
contabilización adecuada hacia atrás
pero sobre todo nos dice y es lo que nos
hace tener esta desconfianza que no se
está siguiendo realmente no hay un
interés por estar monitoreando hacia
dónde va es como si el gobierno quisiera
mantenerse solamente expectante sobre
eso le quería preguntar por qué el
gobierno de andrés manuel lópez obrador
ha insistido en que el manejo de la
pandemia ha sido el adecuado a usted su
opinión y le merecería decir que no
entonces
no por supuesto que no no soy mira
méxico llegó tarde a la pandemia llegó
además en un periodo gubernamental en el
que se estaban haciendo ajustes al
sector salud con un recorte
presupuestario muy grande y en ese
sentido nosotros nunca hemos hecho el
número de pruebas adecuadas no se ha
hecho el rastreo de contacto adecuado se
ha estado respondiendo de manera tardía
a cada una de las etapas
javier gracias a usted por estar con
nosotros continuamos con más noticias
porque en parís entraron en vigor las
medidas de alerta máxima anunciadas este
lunes desde hoy permanecen cerrados los
bares las piscinas y los centros
deportivos durante al menos dos semanas
siguen abiertos los restaurantes pero
con reglas sanitarias más estrictas y un
mayor distanciamiento social para frenar
el aumento de positivos de kobe 19 en la
capital y sus alrededores se reportan
aproximadamente 260 infecciones por cada
100.000 habitantes desde finales de
septiembre cada día hay un promedio de
3.500 nuevos contagios
y argentinas tiene la tasa más alta del
mundo en pruebas positivas de kobe y 19
según el rastreador nuestro mundo en
datos vinculado a la universidad de
oxford casi seis de cada diez personas
se enferma para los investigadores estos
reflejan los bajos niveles de tests y la
aplicación flexible de las reglas de
bloqueo el país austral superó los 800
9000 casos confirmados y en la última
semana los nuevos contagios se
mantuvieron alrededor de los 12 mil 500
diarios
las muertes superaron las 20.000 la
semana pasada
y cambiamos de continente y pasamos a
rusia
allí el crítico del kremlin alexéi
navalni dijo que creía que los servicios
de inteligencia de rusia lo habían
envenenado con el agente nervioso no
[__] porque las autoridades lo veían
como una amenaza antes de las elecciones
parlamentarias del próximo año naval de
apareció en una entrevista de youtube
con un bloguero ruso esta es su primera
comparecencia desde que le dieron de
alta de un hospital de berlín tras
confirmarse su intoxicación naval ni
salió del estado de coma a principios de
septiembre después de colapsar durante
un vuelo de siberia o moscú el pasado
primero de agosto
me siento mejor que el 20 de agosto me
tiemblan las manos si bebo agua de la
botella podrían verlo con más detalle
hago algo así cada día estoy mejorando
estoy trabajando con un fisioterapeuta
hoy comenzó a enseñarme a hacer
malabares así que en algún momento verán
cómo los hago montar en monociclo o
sacar un conejo de un sombrero y
cambiamos de tema la tormenta tropical
en gama arrojo fuertes lluvias e inundó
varias regiones de la costa del golfo de
méxico durante este fin de semana al día
de hoy hay rastros de destrucción y se
cuentan al menos siete personas
fallecidas en imágenes de vídeo
recabadas por la agencia internacional
reuters se pudo ver a varias personas
sacando sus pertenencias y evacuando sus
hogares en villahermosa la capital de
tabasco esto después de que los niveles
del agua del río grijalva alcanzaron su
punto máximo
la tormenta gamma ha dejado a más de
600.000 personas damnificadas en la
costa del golfo de méjico y se sabe que
inundó viviendas
esta es la tormenta número 24 en la
temporada de huracanes del atlántico del
año 2020 y ya se debilitó después de
tocar tierra casi con la fuerza de un
huracán información dada por el centro
nacional de huracanes de estados unidos
que monitorea estos fenómenos
vamos al cáucaso en kirguistán en el
centro de asia se vive en intensos
episodios de inestabilidad política en
medio de las protestas que siguieron a
las elecciones parlamentarias del pasado
domingo los comicios ya fueron
invalidados como belarús kirguistán es
un antiguo miembro de la unión soviética
y en los dos países este año han
estallado de inconformidades con los
líderes dominantes vamos a ver el
informe de esas rojas nos cuenta más
docenas de manifestantes en kirguistán
se abalanzaron contra las puertas del
complejo gubernamental del país mientras
las fuerzas de seguridad respondían con
gases lacrimógenos granadas aturdidoras
y cañones de agua en medio del forcejeo
finalmente lograron entrar a la oficina
presidencial ya las instalaciones de
seguridad del país y ahí liberaron a un
expresidente sentenciado por corrupción
tras un conflicto con el actual
mandatario la protesta llega luego de
que los dos partidos oficialistas de
kylie sanz barrieran en las elecciones
parlamentarias del domingo durante todo
el lunes líderes de oposición y
manifestantes llenaron las calles de
bishkek la capital alegando fraude
electoral a los partidos de gobierno no
les importa la ley hubo tantas
violaciones es un desastre sospechamos
que había violaciones pero no teníamos
idea de que habría tantas de ellas y que
afectaría el resultado de las elecciones
muchas otras personas aún se oponen y la
gente vino aquí a cambiar la injusticia
queremos vivir en un estado democrático
justo donde la legislación funcione y la
gente sea igual todos ellos eran y el
presidente de crisis tan solo un buy-in
bekoff acusó a los manifestantes de
intentar tomarse el poder de forma
ilegal
llamó a la calma y afirmó estar abierto
a la posibilidad de una segunda votación
la pasé en el país y la estabilidad en
la sociedad es más importante que el
mandato de cualquier político es
sugerido que el comité central electoral
investigue cualquier violación durante
este proceso de elección y anule los
resultados si es necesario llamó a todas
las partes a poner el destino del país
por encima de cualquier ambición
política y vuelvan a obedecer la ley o
gadiel del control que tensión susto
este martes la comisión electoral de
kirguistán anuló las elecciones del
domingo para prevenir tensiones en el
país mientras tanto los medios locales
anuncian que el parlamento sostendrá una
reunión de emergencia este miércoles
y se anunció el premio nobel de física
este año la real academia sueca de
ciencias otorgó la mitad del
reconocimiento a un británico roger
penrose y la otra mitad conjuntamente a
la alemana reinhard genzel y a la
estadounidense andrea hes fueron
galardonados por sus investigaciones en
los agujeros negros
estos objetos espaciales compactos de
los cuales no salen ni luz ni materia
demostraron que los agujeros negros son
coherentes con la teoría de la
relatividad y que existe un objeto
compacto supermasivo en el centro de
nuestra galaxia antena que es es sólo la
cuarta mujer en la historia que recibe
el premio de física y la imagen del día
donald trump quitándose la mascarilla en
nuestro sitio web e france24 usted puede
encontrar actualizaciones de esta y
otras noticias de américa latina y del
resto del mundo
y así llegamos al final del informativo
siga con nosotros en france 24 ya
volvemos con más tenemos mucho para
usted
[Música]